- [Narrator] From Peter the
Great to Vladimir Putin,
Russian leaders have
attempted to modernize
and mold the nation's judicial system.
But legal and political experts
say that time after time,
they've undermined the system by using it
to wage war on their political opponents.
- When they really care about something,
they have no trouble using
the laws of blunt instrument,
forbidding criticism of the war,
forbidding people from gathering
in numbers on the street.
All those kinds of things are
very, very crude instruments.
- [Narrator] Charges like espionage
and treason are among the
most powerful weapons.
In recent years, former
US Marine, Paul Whelan,
basketball player, Brittney Griner,
and Wall Street Journal
reporter, Evan Gershkovich
have all been swept up by
the Russian legal system.
- The Russian criminal justice
system is incredibly sticky.
Once you're in, it's very,
very hard to get out.
- [Narrator] While Griner
was released last year
in a prisoner exchange,
Whelan is still imprisoned
and considered wrongfully
detained by the US.
Gershkovich was detained in late March
and accused of espionage.
Both the US government
and the journal vehemently
denied the allegation
and have called for his immediate release.
Here's a look at how
Russia's courts have evolved
but why many of its
features remain the same.
Joseph Stalin presided over a period known
as the Great Terror, where he used the law
to eliminate opponents
and consolidate power.
- There was a provision
in the criminal code,
and it was a crime of
anti-Soviet behavior.
And the problem was,
is that there was no
crisp, clear definition
of what anti-Soviet behavior was,
and so it could be almost anything.
- [Narrator] Historians say
millions of Soviet citizens
were executed, died in labor camps,
or were starved to death under Stalin.
After Stalin's death, Soviet leaders
like Nikita Khrushchev
abandoned mass terror.
- He and the other people
who were surrounding Stalin
made a decision, you know,
not written down anywhere,
but a very clear decision that this kind
of mass terror was not productive.
- [Narrator] But that didn't mean
that political arrests were over.
- It just means that
they no longer took place
on a mass scale.
- [Narrator] Many trials
were closed to the public,
and although people who were arrested
were allowed to have lawyers,
those lawyers had to
be approved by the KGB.
When Mikhail Gorbachev came to power,
he attempted to introduce
reforms to the legal system.
In 1989, Gorbachev changed
the judicial selection process
so that judges were no longer
picked by the Communist Party.
He also instituted a jury system
for the most serious criminal cases.
- What he really wants is
to fix the existing system.
Now, he did this in a very
kind of ham-handed way,
it was destined to fail.
- [Narrator] It was under his
watch that Nicholas Daniloff,
a US news and World Bureau Chief,
was arrested by the KGB
and accused of espionage.
Daniloff had fallen into
a trap set by the KGB.
Eventually, he was released
in a prisoner exchange.
After the fall of the Soviet
Union, there was a rapid shift
from a planned economy
to a market economy,
and Russia's first president
Boris Yeltsin backed a
revamp of the courts.
This led to sweeping changes
within the legal profession,
lawyers were free to start their own firms
and specialize in certain areas of law.
In 1991, a constitutional
court was created,
and in 1993, Russia adopted a constitution
that became the cornerstone
of the legal system.
Judicial review was
introduced for the first time,
meaning the constitutional
court had the power
to declare acts of the legislative
and executive branches
to be unconstitutional.
In 1996, Russia joined
the Council of Europe,
which gave Russians the right to appeal
the decisions of their domestic courts
to the European Court of Human Rights.
However, Yeltsin still managed to go
after opponents using the courts.
But there was a major challenge
in this era, wealthy oligarchs.
- The emergence of the oligarchs brings
a whole element of big
money into the courts,
which is never, never helpful, right?
'Cause in the Soviet period,
it really wasn't that you would go in
and monetarily bribe a judge.
But in the 90s, that definitely happened.
- [Narrator] Yeltsin set the
foundation for a division
of power's approach in government,
but his successor recentralized
power back to the Kremlin.
In 2000, Vladimir Putin came to power
as president of Russia.
He forged ahead with new reforms
and his supporters credited him
with reigning in the power of oligarchs.
He backed a new code of criminal procedure
that on paper gave defendants
the same rights as those in the West.
However, old Soviet habits
reemerged under Putin.
He passed legislation
that consolidated more power in his hands.
One law eliminated
direct popular elections
across the country and gave him the right
to appoint regional leaders in Russia.
- If you control the legislature,
then what is the law?
The other thing that he gets very good at
is returning to this idea
of vague and overbroad laws.
- [Narrator] In 2012, the
Russian punk rock band,
Pussy Riot, was arrested for hooliganism
after protesting Putin's growing power.
- They go back to a crime of hooliganism,
which is just a, you know,
who knows what that means,
and it can mean anything.
- [Narrator] They were
all eventually released.
Then in 2020, Putin passed
several constitutional amendments
that consolidated even
more power in his hands.
Putin could dismiss the Prime Minister
and Prosecutor General whenever he wanted.
Despite decades of efforts
to evolve Russia's justice system,
Putin has brought back
authoritarian control
and many of the elastic aspects
of the Soviet era's justice system.
- We're back to this old Soviet trick
of finding a eternally elastic law
that you can just, you
know, can catch anybody.